[Music]
it's good very good too good you want a
hit of that what's inside your head it's
not gross
colorful stuff
a lime ah
it's vermouth campari and uh gin very
good have a sip i'm not a big drinker
take a sip of samples
i'm not big on kovid so oh
so you'll hang out but you walk do you
think this is [ __ ] safe what we're
doing
yeah i'm the cautious one here
yep caution's out the window but yeah
i'm with you hickey these brights people
are bananas and now they got these high
cars these uh land cruisers and range
rovers their beams go right in your
eyeballs they're right up to your
highlights have you seen the blue ones
oh yeah super focused beams right in
your eyes yeah i think it's the x-men
it's [ __ ] cyclops coming at me i'll
tell you exactly you're burning my
retina
range rover holy [ __ ] that was i pulled
i channeled my normand right there did
you hear that that was a good burp that
was good very good you could hear the uh
the insides
man i'll tell you i got a good wreck for
you guys all right diarrhea
live a little take a chance you know
what diarrhea comes from drinking
chinese food that was too spicy things
that feel good if you don't have
diarrhea once in a while you're not
taking any chances that's right and you
clean out you clean house with diarrhea
it gets all out of you yeah so if you
have diarrhea maybe you had a fish with
chili sauce maybe you have coveted
either way you're living on the edge and
we appreciate you yeah break up those
shits every now and then why do we
always need a log
break it up a long one's boring boring
what am i what am i what am i
michelangelo here am i trying to make a
masterpiece no the hell's going on